>>> HERE AT SKETCHERS, WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON TWO THINGS, MAKING
STYLISH COMFORTABLE SHOES AT AN
AFFORDABLE PRICE.
>> THAT'S WHY EARLIER THIS WEEK,
WHEN KANYE WEST SHOWED UP AT OUR
CORPORATE OFFICE ASKING TO WORK
WITH US, WE SAID NO.
>> NO WAY.
>> NO THANK YOU.
>> AND WE IMMEDIATELY ESCORTED
HIM OUT OF THE BUILDING.
>> LIKE THE REST OF THE COUNTRY,
WE WERE APPALLED BY KANYE'S
HORRIFIC COMMENTS, AND WE VOWED
TO NEVER WORK WITH HIM IN ANY
CAPACITY.
BUT CAN WE ALSO POINT OUT THAT
OF ALL THE COMPANIES HE COULD
HAVE APPROACHED AND BEEN
REJECTED BY, HE CLOSE SKECHERS.
WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A HIP
COMPANY.
>> OF COURSE HE CAME TO US
FIRST.
>> KANYE CAME TO SKECHERS, AND
WE SAID NO.
DO YOU REALIZE HOW INSANELY
SATISFYING THAT IS?
>> I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
SKECHERS EMPLOYEES ARE HEROES.
>> COULD YOU HAVE IMAGINED THAT
LINE TWO YEARS AGO, SKECHERS TOO
GOOD FOR KANYE?
>> CORPORATE WAS LIKE, WE CAN'T
WORK WITH KANYE WEST, HE'S CRAZY
NOW.
I WAS LIKE, NOW?
>> IT TOOK ADIDAS SOME DAYS TO
DECIDE NOT TO WORK WITH HIM.
HE WALKED IN AND WE WERE LIKE,
BYE, BYE BYE, DOOR.
>> AND OF COURSE, HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN A PERFECT PARTNERSHIP.
>> WE INVENTED SHOES YOU CAN
WASH IN A WASHING MACHINE.
>> BUT, AGAIN, WE WOULD NEVER
PARTNER WITH HIM.
>> NEVER.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> BESIDES, WHAT WOULD YOU EVEN
CALL A KANYE SKECHERS SHOE ANY
WAY?
THE SKEEZY?
THAT'S NOT BAD.
>> BUT WE'RE NOT DOING IT.
>> RIGHT.
BECAUSE OF THE ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> I'M PROUD TO WORK FOR
SKECHERS.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME I SAID
THAT?
>> ALL WE WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW IS
WHERE WE STAND AND TO RECOGNIZE
HOW COOL THIS MAKES US LOOK.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S ALL ABOUT
US.
BUT IT'S NOT LIKE ALL BIRDS IS
FIGHTING THE FIGHT.
>> I'M SURPRISED WE HAVEN'T
HEARD ANYTHING FROM CROCS.
>> AND TO THINK, KANYE WEST
COULD HAVE BEEN MY BOSS.
THAT IS -- TERRIFYING.
>> SO THANKS BUT NO THANKS,
KANYE.
>> WE DON'T NEED YOU.
>> WE DON'T STAND WITH US.
>> WE MIGHT MESS UP IN THE
FUTURE, BUT WE DIDN'T THIS TIME.
>> AND BESIDES, I'M SURE KANYE
WILL FIND SOME MORALLY DUBIOUS
COMPANY TO WORK WITH INSTEAD.
>> HE SURE WILL.
IT'S ME, MIKE LINDELL, FOUNDER
OF MY PILLOW, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANNOUNCE WE ARE STARTING TIES
WITH KANYE WEST EFFECTIVE